- [Narrator] The first sandwich in history
was thought to be created by Rabbi Hillel,
who made this meal for Passover.
- You've got apple and horseradish,
which I know sounds disgusting,
but it somehow works.
- [Narrator] But this meal
wasn't known as sandwich
until John Montagu the
fourth Earl of Sandwich
came along in the 18th century.
- I am John Montagu
and I invented the
sandwich not you Subway!
You owe me money!
- [Narrator] Our legendary tale begins
in 18th century England
where Montagu was on a
24 hour gambling bender.
(dramatic music)
- Losers, losers, I'm the winner.
- Hey guys, here's your
meat, hope you enjoy it.
- [Narrator] Montagu did not like any
interruptions while gambling.
It's possible that his
impatience led to his invention.
- Come on deal the next hand.
- I am eating, you old chump.
- There, do give us a minute.
- I want to win my money back.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] The story suggests
that eating and gambling at the same time
did not happen in Montagu's world.
This could be because player's
hands were busy dealing
with a fork and a knife
or if they ate with their hands
they would get their cards dirty.
- Disgusting.
(claps)
- Hey guys, what can I get ya?
- I want roast beef between
two pieces of bread.
Now go.
- [Narrator] Roast beef between
two slices of toasted bread
would be the official first sandwich.
- Hello, I want you to try my sandwich.
- OK.
- No.
- [Narrator] It was amazing.
Montagu can now hold the food in one hand
while gambling with the other.
Which led everybody to say,
"Hey, I'll have the same as Sandwich."
And the story goes that this is how
the lunch time favorite got it's name
and why we continue to refer
to this meal as sandwich.